hello friends i'm alana and i don't
think i've ever made a video like this
before
i've certainly never recorded a video in
the particular mood that i'm in right
now
it's like 11 p.m and i'm wearing my
pajamas but i was just like
i feel like i need to do this because
i'm sort of going insane
let me start out by saying that i feel
like i have
pretty much no party loyalty
or platform loyalty whatsoever i have
had both a playstation and an xbox
and a nintendo system actually literally
my entire life i've always had
all three of those systems still play on
pc probably more than any of them i'm
actually excited to play horizon zero
dawn on pc
very soon so you know you are absolutely
entitled to like whatever platform
you like and like whatever exclusives
you like whatever games you like
and everything i'm about to say is not
about changing your mind on any of that
none of this is going to be me telling
you that i think that you should buy an
xbox or that you should start using the
windows store
what i really need to talk about
is how just [ __ ] insane it is
that we are not paying any attention
to a multi-million dollar corporation in
an industry that i love
i love the games industry i made it my
life intentionally i left every person
that i have ever met
to move to a significantly lower salary
job in cities where i have to live in
shoebox apartments
just so that i could be at the heart of
the games industry while also
acknowledging that that industry
frequently [ __ ] disappoints me at how
money hungry it is
there was a while where i think ubisoft
was my favorite publisher like around
assassin's creed 2
and ub arts like i was so into them and
now
i'm like cool 60 and then you
artificially
inflate the level system so that i will
be incentivized to spend money to level
up faster
cool cool cool cool i never thought
bethesda would do it
i never i always thought they'd be on my
side
here we are playstation exclusives and
nintendo exclusives still both do
very good jobs of not uh heavily
monetizing
their single player experiences however
that's because those single-player
experiences are designed to sell
hardware
so that they will make you know 30 from
every third-party game that you buy on
their platform so that they get your
playstation plus subscription or your
nintendo online service subscription
all services to which i am spending my
money i do always i just always want to
note that when we talk about
yes there are exceptions and it's
usually the hardware
or platforms and of course they do want
to acknowledge
playstation making some goddamn bangers
i still think god of war is probably my
favorite game of the generation
however okay it was [ __ ] okay all
right
the fact that we are not talking about
how every single game every single game
from the xbox game showcase today is
coming day
and date to game pass is [ __ ]
nuts game pass right now for ultimate
which combines
xbox live for the record and pc
and console is a dollar for your first
month it then goes up to fifteen dollars
i think just consoles is ten dollars
just pc right now i'm pretty sure they
have a deal for five dollars
basically it equals out ultimate is the
best deal fact is
no matter what games you play or what
platform you like you should be cheering
from the [ __ ] rooftops that someone
in the games industry
that could be doing things so
differently has every single game that
they showed at a showcase today
available to you for a 15
a month subscription every single
xbox studio first party title which is
13 studios very good studios
ninja theory obsidian turn 10 playground
rare
compulsion in exile mojang uh
i feel bad that i'm forgetting all of
them but you get the point
all of their games every single one
on game pass 15 a month
oh my god it's just so nuts that today
that happened and nobody's talking about
it that my entire twitter timeline is
just talking about halo
and how good it does or does not look
based on your personal preference
when a company in the games industry
which again i love but is
has gotten just so disappointingly money
hungry from my perspective
is giving people these games for such a
small amount of money
and we aren't just like holy [ __ ] props
even if you're not into those games
i would want a i'm not into those games
i don't care about any of the games on
that list i don't even like any of those
studios
[ __ ] double fine which would concern me
if you said that but
you get the point you should still be
like props though
i like video games i like consuming
video games
i would like to do that for less money
right
again i'm not trying to tell you that i
want you to buy an xbox i'm not trying
to tell you that this means that xbox is
winning the console wars i'm literally
completely removing myself from all of
that discourse
i'm not trying to tell you that xbox
doesn't benefit from this in certain
ways
all i am trying to say is that as people
who play video games
i feel like we've gotten so caught up in
the console wars
that it is crazy
that this is something that again one of
these multi-billion
dollar corporations is doing and
everyone's like
i don't care about those games though
okay but what if you praised it
in any case because then other companies
might consider doing it
i guess that wouldn't necessarily work
it's the game pass has to make money for
other companies to want to do it
but even if you're a person who has no
[ __ ] interest in any of that
the fact that i feel like people aren't
acknowledging
that is so weird have we just gotten
that used to spending 60
on games and then having them have micro
transactions and launching broken plenty
of the time anyway
like is that just the point that we're
out there we're like 15 a month
for 100 plus games who cares
what how what how is this not
incredible you don't have to buy into it
i'm not asking you to do that but it is
objectively
the best deal in video games right now
the fact that that showcase happened
today and every single one of those
games
is coming to game pass
for people who have a very expensive
hobby because gaming is a luxury hobby
it is expensive
there are a lot of people who can't
afford to buy multiple games a year i
couldn't when i was in high school
i was pre-ordering stuff just so i could
pay it off slowly with my income that
was coming from working at eb games
i got those staff discounts i still had
to be choosy imagine if i had had game
pass back then
for every person who can't afford to buy
more than one game a year
this deal is insane it is just so
good for gamers and if anyone follows
suit
it means we get to enjoy the things we
like way
way way cheaper there are potentially
long time implications like i'm not
telling you that this system is flawless
either it could change the development
cycles
uh people have speculated that devs are
losing money um i would say microsoft
probably is going to lose money with
having all of their first party titles
available on game pass it means for me
as a game pass subscriber
i'm not going to buy a first party xbox
title in theory ever again
why would i i have game pass but several
devs actually have come forward about
how having their games on game pass
actually helped with sales ultimately um
descendants is an example
it's a game that i play on game pass
that by being on game pass
ended up just selling more from the day
it started being on gamecast because
more people hear about it and know what
it is and it gets that
advertising boost that it can't get
otherwise i mean that's how rocket
league took off it was a
[ __ ] ps plus game game pass just does
that
but with more games basically i think
descenders is actually coming to ps4
next month maybe maybe sooner even and
will ultimately sell better and do
better for that indie studio because it
was on game pass
so i just kind of wanted to get ahead of
that again that's not even my point
there are
criticisms you could make of it my point
is just it's so
[ __ ] pro consumer it is so
good for gamers it is such a good deal
you save
so much money it is nuts that someone in
the gaming space is doing this
when a majority of the publishers
again aside from those hardware holders
who have reason to try to get you in
with
big blockbuster single-player titles so
that you will buy their hardware so that
you'll
get on their subscription services
because hardware for the record is not
the big profit maker in the industry
which i guess is why gameplay
obviously being very us centric in my
pricing language here since i live here
a hundred dollars when i was in
australia
the fact that we don't have to do that
and people don't give a [ __ ] is so
confusing to me
it doesn't have to be something that
appeals to you but it is something that
is
objectively good
that you would want other companies to
do it's just
what is happening it's just console wars
gotten so intense that we just don't
even
care about this anymore like what why do
you not
care about money oh
boy okay i should wrap this up i feel
like i got my point across hopefully
there are probably going to be things
that i've forgotten this is why i don't
record a
video when impassioned i just think that
no matter who you are
you gotta recognize how [ __ ] crazy
this deal is
in this industry come on
god